you know there's you know not to say
there's people not doing good content on
youtube but the amount of
original ideas you can put on youtube i
feel like there's a lot less now because
one someone with bigger resources and
is like probably smarter than you is
probably doing it and two um i feel like
a lot of the original content i see is
now on twitch
and i i don't know if that's just
because i'm not being recommended the
right videos on youtube
yeah i know i definitely do just think
that right now we're kind of in like a
golden age of like
twitch creativity like there was just so
many ideas that people
thought would be like either too much
effort or wouldn't you know
reap the benefits of doing it live yeah
because there was just so much room for
error but now people
have gotten to the point and there's
enough people i feel now on twitch
that there's at least one person who's
gonna be like this might be risky
yeah for a lot of different reasons but
i'm gonna just try it and see if it
lands
and a lot of the times it does land in
ways that no one was really expecting me
like oh you can do that on twitch
yeah and it'd be really [ __ ]
successful well then i'm gonna try and
do it too and it's just like
i don't know i feel it's just like
feeding the creativity
to more and more streamers being like oh
you know i feel like we're past that
point of just
get in front of a camera and just start
playing a game yeah we're way past that
i don't know if you
were ever like watching twitter and this
is the thing though like marbles was
like a huge thing at one point
what yeah like watching a bunch of
marbles go down a course and like seeing
which one won
like rude goldberg machines or like just
like it was like there's like
simulations of like marbles
and people would like bet on the marbles
like i think ludwig did this as well oh
i think tecton did it as well
yeah it's like you just you can assign
things to like the balls yeah just let
all these balls go down whichever one
wins you like you know
that kind of like salty bets i don't
know what that is
salty bets is i i'm not on 100 sure
about this but
i believe someone made it like a program
right where it's
they pitted two characters against each
other in a fighting game i'm not sure
what the fighting game was i know what's
wrong about this because they have like
[ __ ] sonic going against like chun li
yeah yeah yeah i know yeah um no it's
not like
then and people would be betting on the
winner even though it was a completely
you know ai battle
right no it's just like the streamer i
can't remember exactly because i never
watched it fully speaking
i think it's like they're like reacting
to like these marbles in virtual
like games going down it was really
bizarre it's like horseradish betting
but like
i find that like stuff like that does
well on twitch chat when you're
overreacting
well i mean that's the whole reason why
at one point or i mean i would argue
still to this day
people love watching people do gotcha on
stream right because it's like
people losing their [ __ ] to pngs it's
like well of course i'm gonna watch this
this is ridiculous
i'm gonna watch it and play a part i
play and play a part i can say that
because i've done gotcha on stream and i
have overreacted and it's been [ __ ]
amazing
oh my god i got something i got the
waifu you know it's like
it's the same it's the same philosophy
right bro it's just a png bro it's just
a png this is png man but then the
amount of pogs i'm seeing in the chat is
like saying otherwise
it's not because yeah i i guess to me
the one thing you get away you can
do on twitch or live streaming that you
can't do with youtube content is just
really have this community aspect
right and it's something that i feel is
getting more and more
like it's before it was seen as like
youtube comments are just that
the thing that comes after the content
it's the reaction to the content but now
like
the comments itself and the reaction to
the to the content that's being made is
also part of the content itself and
that's
what i what i see being like kind of
like the future
and the future of online content and how
it's kind of evolving right now and this
at least that is
that's that's how i see it right because
there's
like even even with like twitch streams
that have been put on youtube
you know i feel like half the fun is
lost if they don't have the twitch chat
on the content itself yeah you miss a
lot of the context itself and if it's
just like a stream highlights
uh without the twitch shot itself i i
feel like you're missing
half of the content itself no i i
absolutely agree like i feel a lot of it
gets taken out of context where like
if you don't see the reaction it doesn't
seem as
epic yes it actually is like it's still
epic
yeah but when you see a twitch chat on
the screen
going [ __ ] crazy you're like oh this
is really epic
okay this is an epic gamer moment right
now i don't know if it's like placebo or
whatever but it's like the moment you
see a hype twitch chat
suddenly you're like well i have to get
hyped too [ __ ] because when you're
watching on mobile
who the [ __ ] has the chat open on the
side because it like squishes down
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like i'm not
gonna [ __ ] watch this [ __ ] with the
chat
just like put it just put it on the
stream and then that way it's the best
viewing experience as well yeah
yeah i mean like what i mean i don't
watch twitch on the phone
most of the time um i mean you know
sometimes i want to watch twitch and um
i'll watch it every now and then like if
i'm on the train somewhere you know it's
just seeing like oh someone's streaming
whatever yeah i guess do you guys watch
a lot of like
twitch and live streaming yourself or do
you watch the highlights
i mostly just like jump into like one of
my friends streams if they're streaming
just say hi
yeah i normally watch my mates streaming
yeah so what are you up to huh yeah
i literally used it as an excuse to just
catch up with my friends
like i could like message you on twitter
dms or whatever but like
you're here right now you're gonna
respond to me i do watch highlights too
um just not as often i prefer
i still prefer normal youtube videos on
youtube right right right
um and yeah i mean i don't i mean
there's so much [ __ ] i got to watch as
well like anime and i i love watching
anime what is that who's watching it no
you don't know her
but yeah you know when i want to keep
doing all the things i like so it's
difficult to keep up with everything
yeah it's kind of like there's just so
much content that i want to watch now
and there's not enough time anymore
like yeah tell me about it literally
literally literally can't get more first
world problem than that
right there's just too much to do
exactly